so what's up guys prestige here hello
with another urban experience the little
buddy urban next to us here what's up
bro that's kind of creepy head turn he
up there's nits all right well hello
everybody my name is prestige and this
is hair been experienced if you knew the
series which I doubt it but if you knew
and this is kind of my survival world
than I do stuff and now i have with hair
bring you stuff with another mod but not
Terran he's chill and we're playing one
point six point two so had not updated
many mods that's why and I've better or
not but yeah so I've also i implemented
another mod recently called millionaire
or something of the sort in some other
language millionaire and it's a mod that
makes villages and just better so i
found a village earlier on so we're
gonna go check it out and they trade
lots of stuff so blocks let's take some
wood let's tail on something Oliver
would just take some wood I'm some
saying just in case glass we have a lot
of college tell me so we can take some
of that um I'm hoping they're not going
to be buying dirt but maybe that who
knows maybe they'll buy some netherrack
some glowstone they should buy some iron
maybe some gold moves in gold who knows
maybe piece of red sooner two piece of
coal or two and you're not going any
diamond since I don't think about any
dimes I also take some smooth stone
anything here we want to take ta they
prob won't bite aunty but a gravel maybe
I think I think we're good so let's go
check it out so you see if I click and v
is it bake tells me comp Takanawa
inactive to the people are moving around
stuff is 557 meat metris to the
southwest I think it's this way yeah
it's effing this way are so we're gonna
keep going
now it actually the game will not show
you what is until you get really close
and it'll say no village within 2,000
like 2km 2000 km 2000 meters or two
kilometers when this is like 500 meters
away so it won't show you until you
actually find it so we're gonna go check
it out and we're going to say hello to
all the friendly villagers and hopefully
trade some stuff maybe build some stuff
I don't know we'll see since you can
really you can like it build on the
villages you can give them supplies you
can get stuff built are you gonna be
like oh can you build me this you can
get higher application you can do quests
there's a lot of stuff that our buddy
hairbrained will be held in this
accomplished with his teleportation
powers like this I'll look at that nice
travel so much easier up not by the tail
they'll jump you should be seeing it
soon it's only 200 2 meters away dunno
interpretation so let's eat some bread
so start reaching our health and I'm
sort out just in case oh let's get some
pigs Adama mi other sword with the fire
enchantment to get the goods off these
pigs cook pork sauce but it's still good
nonetheless okay there it is oh yeah the
village is right there sorry Erik all
pumpkins what we got you guys got your
pumpkins you know we got to get pumpkins
see that breaks it okay this place is
like instantly so we're good sorry about
the lag again not the best computer no
I'm uploading video but I guess my
computer has been like oh you're doing
stuff you know it just lets it short
straight it's it's kind of bad but hope
you guys have chosen our so this is the
village of Takanawa and so yeah
basically the villages have a lot of
different types like you can have a
nordic village a like they're they there
are a few different
bc's not species with the races of
people this might be like Egyptian or
something I really don't know yeah uh no
all gums occupation 10 so they're 10
people all right I'll be right there so
usually one person runs in trades with
you hello I don't read your stuff all
right so this is worth 20 d whatever
that is that's bread is worth six bars
with numbers with eight so we're three
call the stone is 1111 okay since
cobblestone one what is 1 i'm not going
to be selling any wood but i will sell
cobblestone and you see so like I guess
a hundred of these is one of these so
they won't sell given oh they bought all
of my Collison art let's sell some wood
oh I'm not wood stone okay um let's so a
little bit of this and this is worth 20
I have a lot to spare um I'm pup voice a
little i was in the Iowa tech whats Alan
already did see their loss of how to
stock question these types of blocks are
made for free by the village and are
therefore okay they used to build
buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh
whatever i don't i don't see that much
so 16 so these are incident i can get
even amounts of those is that just a
ladder brick mold no no no that does are
so mud birth to 16 what 22 so this is
like buildings have no construction in
progress okay Eileen need more mud
bricks um my brakes how do you make him
a mud-brick I don't know how to make mud
Burke and they're like too many items
mod to show me I got so yeah these are
like a locked chest so I can look in
them but I can't take anything out of
them mud brick how do you make that
let's go let's go see you if we're
talking bit hello um Oh dr. this person
possible housing nothing's available
because I'm not cool enough to these
people I want to be cool to people this
is the villa and santosh if I die
apologies if i pronounce everything
terribly hey any of you but these are
mud bricks just use the ease of the guys
house okay for oakwood making bricks be
interesting enough to lulu too dude
massey and my house hello you've walked
through the door and talk to you we're
good to you oh whatever nope even ok so
this village really doesn't seem to have
too much going on can't really uh hmm
relations help local trade yada yada
Timomatic what up um so the only guy I
can talk I want like a quest
I'll be right there by Luigi oh I'm
running out the window no no no no come
back what rude all right now looks like
pies and Indian objects in buildings in
Eden villagers um sure well let's what
is this like right click it village
leaders I really don't care about
reading all this okay well you you can
have this back don't you watch this no
okay I'm wish mr. on the ground I break
even envision i know i'm at none of my
inventory i don't know how to make them
I don't care whatever no is there
anything else we can by looking back
some so like sandstone slabs path I'll
buy some of these dang these are
expensive he's almost it's like one of
these like he's a fire no thank ya I
didn't want to buy all of these or
whatever let's go let's go back to our
house and let's uh hello sheep let us so
yeah we got gypped hard obviously trade
it all my iron for some sand some paths
and shifty peoples but yeah let's go
back to our house and let's see what
little bit of renovations and don't want
to make it look a little prettier yeah I
can't really tell for into non little
world 001 we r load you can do it I know
you can so i think i'm about yeah I am
gonna weigh can TP oh yeah let's go with
I'm going to
the mouse yes I literally just hard with
this like it doesn't really load I get a
chunk loaded all you can be soon don't
worry no one's people like never eats
all right so yeah I was kind of thinking
like this we can make gravel it's like
connected together that Oh irritate
noses boop boop no not um there we go
all right now let's sort out everything
so in blocks I can throw pumpkins I can
throw uuuuu uuuu you also you and you
and here I can throw this I got that
yeah all right we're gonna get arrows
fun no I'm like very error I use arrows
for shooting stuff there all right
leather mother can go now yeah food
spook boop boop boop I've tend in here
they don't know what you need are like
what culture it is well I'm going to
need some gravel though ogre of gravel
where's the grout there is it gravel to
stop should be let's sleep sleep at all
full with it all then the good all in
conversations and languages that I don't
know all right let's start placing
scrabble oh no oh dang
yeah dude so we're gonna you're just
going to connect the fishing check it's
a good idea so we can have it go 12 like
that that'll be good I'm bum bum bum bum
bum I'm place it like mmm actually tough
go out one more orcutt to have like that
may be called fancy okay so i'll show
you guys one saying so hear me out and
put it out what good like that
no I don't really like it just lay some
gravel there and well at least that's
connected so basically whenever we make
a structure we're gonna connect it with
our graph the road follow the gravel
fork road well that's when grapple
pirkled look like that'd be crazy
probably be very disgusting hey science
on the sexes sand it all right now what
else hmm coupled with us hitter let's
test it out to see if it's I think it's
better Oh too low way to go hit it I
don't think so are we gonna have to go
to skate ok I guess it was my
imagination our song I think we can make
like a better structure form animals
yeah we'll keep call the cell but we'll
add more pens so we can have like sheep
and pigs and chickens and shoot at
anything else with but uh it looks so
empty um so we're going to need
cobblestone in the droves and we're
gonna need some planks I'll make it a
data out of out get out of that where
can we get a birch wood planks in
Birchwood look legit so let's turn
basically most of our birch wood into
virtual planks and we're going to need a
lot of fences fans and I you know and
make more sense you do this because I'm
going to make a lots
that is a lot of fences so that should
be enough and let's go inspect since
we're just like build around it so
that's gonna be the cow one that'll make
one right next to it just a short list
down with the speech it is really
annoying to have any cows so I'm just
gonna do this I'll run away
all right that's a little bit better
still allowed as heck but a little more
bearable because they're not like super
glitching out ok so that is one so one
two three four five six seven eight
including the sides so one two three
four five six seven eight besides ok I
can just match it why not now I want to
make each of us so let's go 122 good
u2's good just good up to thank oh now
so we're gonna I'm getting a break this
one 2012 for that one no damn one cow
move one to one thing oh yeah two and
one two all right shuffle okay okay now
I'm gonna top it with the birch wood and
also wants me stop with the Birchwood
except mmm the one in slabs yes I should
be good doo-doo-doo-doo-doo
doo-doo-doo-doo-doo once i finish this
other pen I will and if they also do
stairs let's do slabs make a good amount
of them I'll just make the rest of us
into slaves
yeah alright basically to staff to slap
that should be more than enough all
right now let's tower all right up now
watch ah actually a faster ova like this
ha and uh okay so this is this me
outline actually many more Wow obviously
this is the outline of it did you know
that i need the auto switch mod make it
so much easier to like do work and stuff
but it blew put a little boy think i
need more let's break in this and oh
let's he's noms the norms are actually a
single ND hip alright guys hope you
enjoyed the video make sure you leave a
like grape gum subscribe if you did and
i'll see you all next time peace out